[Musica]
volevo iniziare questo talk con due
domande quanto spesso ti guardi il volto
quanto spesso vi palpate le labbra per
controllare la consistenza e osservare
le mucose interne
se non ci fosse stata la foto magari
avreste pensato al volto invece
io parlavo del sotto invece che del
sopra e sono venuto anche preparato
mi chiamo violeta benini è solo una
divulgatrice
nella vita ho scelto di dare voce alle
vulve
mi sono laureata in ostetricia a 29 anni
con pò tardi rispetto alla media ma
questo perché ho fatto altri percorsi
prima ero grande ed ero consapevole di
quello che volevo diventare una libera
professionista e avere il mio studio
dove poter accogliere le donne e offrire
loro tutto il tempo di cui hanno bisogno
come tante tantissime altre all'inizio
volevo assistere i party in casa e così
ho fatto tanti corsi di formazione avrei
dovuto invece comprendere che non era la
mia strada
il primissimo incontro è stato sulle
coppette mestruali
ma com'è che dagli adattamenti in sono
finita su questo palco palco a parlarvi
di vulve
per dirvelo
vi devo raccontare un pezzettino della
mia storia che è fatta di tanti
ribaltamenti ma anche di tante rinascite
nel 2011 ho iniziato una relazione
tossica poi l'uomo in tre anni mi ha
completamente annullata non ero più io
da lui già ci arrivavo un po acciaccata
con i muscoli del pavimento pelvico
troppo tesi vigili imi orgasmi erano
timidi erano difficili
avevo la sindrome dell'ovaio policistico
che un brutto squilibrio ormonale che
era causato da l'iperinsulinemia che io
chiamo pre diabete
in questa relazione il mio sistema
immunitario crollo completamente avevo
allergia agli acari che mi portavano
bronchiti per cui devo prendere
antibiotici che unito all'allergia
all'anello vaginale mi dava delle
candide frequentissime questo unito ai
muscoli tesi mi ha portato la vulvodinia
ora per fortuna se ne sente parlare
molto ma ai miei tempi quasi per niente
io andavo dai medici
e non mi aiutavano avevo un bruciore
fisso costante avevo la sensazione di
avere tanti piccoli tagli mi sembrava di
avere degli spilli che si conficcavano
nella criteri de sulle labbra
non potevo più mettere i pantaloni
stretti i collant o andare in bicicletta
toccarmi mi faceva male figuriamoci
masturbarmi o fare sesso
i miei amici mi davano sempre le stesse
risposte mi dicevano di prendere i
farmaci come la pillola la metformina mi
dicevano di respirare per rilassare
questo perineo mi dicevano rilassati per
gli orgasmi
a un certo punto mi sono ricordata del
consiglio di un vecchio professore che
era quello di imparare la fitoterapia
perché noi ostetriche non possiamo
prescrivere farmaci e così noi stata
fare tanti corsi e ora felicemente la
uso questa fitoterapia che una scienza
veramente in cui si usano i principi
attivi delle piante per fare degli
integratori che si possono usare a
insieme ai farmaci o quando si può al
posto di essi e aiuto molto le mie
pazienti con le loro varie disfunzioni
finalmente mi sono liberata di
quell'uomo e mi sono presa una pausa dal
lavoro e mi sono presa cura di me
dopo un pochino un sexy shop e mi chiese
di organizzare degli incontri su gli
orgasmi e sul pavimento pelvico di cui
io non sapevo nulla perché l'università
allora ma anche ancora forma veramente
poco così ho iniziato a studiare
studiare più studiamo più di tavole miei
pazienti e più ascoltavo me stessa più
tutto aveva un senso non era più sotto
sopra è anche tutte le mie disfunzioni
avevano un senso erano correlate un
giorno mia sorella mi chiese di
spiegargli una cosa sui suoi genitali e
io glielo spiegato liszt e caspita ho
compreso tutto sei riuscito a spiegarmi
un tema così difficile e delicato in
maniera comprensibile facile dovresti
fare dei video devi diventare la vagina
o lo ga d'italia
e così piano piano iniziato e sui mai
social ho parlato parlo tuttora delle
cose che il mio corpo conosce meglio e
sono le difficoltà con gli orgasmi il
dolore pelvico
gli squilibri ormonali e anche le
violenze psicologiche
io sono una persona un po particolare
sono molto curiosa e non mi fermo finché
non comprendo come funzionano le cose le
avevo smontare e sono anche una persona
multi potenziale ovvero mi interesso di
tanti argomenti di studio le
approfondisco e poi trovo le connessioni
tra tutte queste cose e questo mi ha
permesso di creare il mio metodo che
parte da un'anamnesi lunga dove già
nelle risposte delle pazienti io trovo
la soluzione ai loro problemi e loro
trovano consapevolezza
o ideato anche una serie di esercizi
basati sul corpo e anche sul pavimento
pelvico che uniti alla meditazione si
adattano perfettamente a quasi tutte le
disfunzioni ovviamente uso la
fitoterapia e anche tanti sex toys
in questi anni ho compreso che se
vogliamo che cambino le cose noi non
possiamo stare fermi
ci dobbiamo attivare dal basso perché
anche se il sopra ci vuole ancora
bloccate
e sfoglia su quel lettino
noi ci possiamo attivare ed è per questo
che dico che vogliamo la stessa quantità
di studi che hanno i maschi perché noi
siamo veramente studiate meno se cercate
su pubmed gli studi sono molto pochi
e sui social io parlo di questo i nostri
corpi sono considerati
male non sono non hanno lo stesso peso
di quelli maschili la sindrome di niente
andatevela a cercare dopo non dovrebbe
esistere
ci devono chiedere il permesso prima di
toccarci le domande non sono idiote e le
visivo know una risposta e se non di
sovizzo un professionista
cambia lo puoi denunciare chi ti ha
fatto una violenza
ma soprattutto che si può rinascere
dalle cose più brutte e che non esistono
limiti alla felicità
per dare in stessa importanza al sotto e
portarlo verso il sopra
noi vogliamo che le nostre patologie
siano studiate vogliamo ricevere una
diagnosi in tempi adeguati
riprendere il possesso del nostro
piacere e dei nostri orgasmi non ci
vogliamo più vergognare di avere una
vulva o di avere le mestruazioni
vogliamo gli stessi diritti dei peni
io ho un progetto io voglio fondare una
una fondazione
perché voglio poter offrire
un'assistenza
accessibile ma soprattutto un aiuto
concreto alle persone che soffrono di
dolore pelvico cronico e che attualmente
passano dieci quindici anni in attesa di
una diagnosi voglio formare gli altri
professionisti con il mio metodo ma
soprattutto voglio fare ricerca perché
solo con i dati alla mano si può
realmente cambiare un approccio
terapeutico
io da sola non lo posso fare
ma se noi diventiamo tutti miglior
migliaia di divulgatrici e di
divulgatori potremmo ribaltare il sotto
con il sopra r riempire il mondo di peri
e clitoridi felici e tu vieni a google
vale come
[Applauso]
[Musica]